last week you know we got copies of doom
like barely before I guess we didn't
even get them before it came out we came
out on release day we actually got
copies on release day run we got in a
few hours early because Australia
technically got it on release day which
is in the past for future it depends a
trail looking at it I guess and but it
sort of turned up this whole discussion
again about she know Oh red flag start
wave get start to get waved whenever
again comes out and big publisher
decides to hold back review copies and
there's a bunch people tweeting about it
over the weekend we were having a big
chat about kevin van order was to embed
it seemed like in his in his
professional experience this there was
no ever never really any correlation
between it and Peter what do you think
you've been reviewing games for a long
long time you've had early access to
games you've probably been in a couple
of review events I'm guessing as well
and you've had games not turn up and had
to review them as quickly as you can is
there any sort of correlation between
that do you ever sort of see red flags
waving whenever publishers decide to not
give us early access to stuff it
certainly makes you wonder but I would
be lying if I said that there is a like
definite correlation that I've noticed
right you know I mean sure yeah there
are times when games are not good and a
publisher knows that because I don't
know if anyone else out there knows that
but they hire people to review games
before they send out copies for reviews
known as internal mock reviews and a
large part of mock reviews is to sort of
allocate things like marketing budgets
and stuff like that isn't it sure yeah
yeah you know to understand like okay
what are we going to face how do we plan
accordingly to match that so yeah I'm
certain they're instances when the game
did not show up on time because they
knew it was going to be a poor
experience I think they just gonna be a
Friday the 13th joke I really don't know
why we didn't get doom all right before
the release day um but I'm not that
bothered like as someone whose job it is
to review the game yeah it's like a
paint on my butt but I don't really care
because doing ended up being it's really
really good and I don't I don't know why
they would have been nervous about it
may be because the multiplayer isn't so
hot snap map on the multiplayer maybe
they've maybe they were worried about
people putting as reviews without having
experienced that stuff at a time yeah I
don't know but like but it's just a
short while yeah you know like there's
there's stuff you can do and fall out
that kind of falls into that camp but
not multiplayer but you know like just
weird stuff and we got that plenty of
time all right um but yeah I know in my
experience I think it's you know it's a
case-by-case basis there's not like some
conspiracy you know especially between
publishers and outlets like you know we
kind of just roll with whatever they're
willing to give us and in this case oh
well we can get it early let's talk
about a couple of instances that have
happened because you said it is on a
case-by-case basis I mean almost the
opposite of what's happened with doom is
what's happened with homefront is that
we actually did get that relatively
early week on learning some stage last
week yeah we got a Wednesday right
believe yeah yeah which I thought have
been a game that could they get a held
off i mean the reviews aren't super hot
at the moment right and that window of
time is pretty typical for a lot of
games even so really big games which you
know kind of sucks but yeah i mean who
knows why they didn't hold that back
right you wonder if they want people to
buy the game on launch day to not be
scared off by poor reviews then they
might hold it back and i think that's
why people some people think that's the
case but it's evidence of the fact that
that's maybe not the case all the time
when we see a game like home friendship
now i think that a lot of the reason
people have that expectation is because
of what happens with film criticism film
releases right so quite often with film
releases if if and this is much more due
to quality if the quality and they are
anticipating bad reviews they will not
screen it to the press now normally
national press screenings for movies
happen you know the Monday all the
tuesday before the friday release date
okay enough time for that week's
national newspapers and stuff to
circulate out quite often they if if a
movie skips that that press schedule
then the critics will have to go see it
on friday friday morning with the
republic right they miss and that's
because for film you know the friday and
saturday or the opening weekend box
office is that is the most critical
period if you can protect at least your
friday and saturday night then then
which is obviously not the case with
games which have a much bigger obviously
really the first few weeks of release
are very important but you know for film
studios is much more about protecting
that friday night sound and light box
office and so if they're worried that a
film's going to receive negative
criticism there
often not show it to the press so that
they can least get a good friday night
maybe even a Saturday night before the
bad word starts to spread around it but
as as Pete says I mean it's it's it's
really not the case and we see so many
different examples from you know I mean
you know a few years ago ubisoft with
with unity where the right embargo was
hot six hours after the game had
actually been released right you know
and obviously that game had some
technical issues 2 to 2 examples like
doom where you know again I'm no idea
why well I mean I think I don't even
know if they said to us it was due to
the online components but obviously I
mean that's a that is an element and
when you do get games that have a large
online component to them that is often
the case where where they'll want to try
them in the world which is obviously how
we review games anyway we won't put a
game out and there's a large online
component until we've tested it in
public environment anyway so yeah it
seems like it can happen not as often as
the film world but it can happen but
it's all it almost seems like the
inverse of that happens as often then
that we just get late copies it's there
it's not as easy as you can say oh yeah
no early reviews are the games terrible
yeah you know it doesn't work like a lot
of people you know did not like the new
starfox right I can show up weeks I have
time yeah what about on charters was the
embargo for the US I think we had just
about over a week hmm with the game
maybe a little bit less yeah yeah it's
funny how it works out I I wonder with
doom as well was it something to do with
the fact that they were releasing on a
friday which is typical for the European
market but obviously not the case over
here well they can send his digital
codes right and so we're not necessarily
dealing with like market distribution
well I was I was thinking maybe they
needed some like distance from uncharted
or something both are landing in a sort
of weird maybe a situation here do you
mean mean yeah that's not possible it
could have been totally logistical too
yeah you know and we would just never
know yeah maybe they just couldn't get
them out on time it's weird how this
stuff works anyway thanks for chatting
about it because it is you same thing
and especially like before I was sort of
involved in the price I always want I
think people wonder about this stuff a
lot of the time and they wonder we know
what gears are sort of working in the
background and the reality I think when
you come in and see it is that actually
there are so many gears working that
there it's not like there is some sort
of i don't know like quid pro quo thing
happening it's just a
sometimes people work within the limits
and sometimes things fall out of the
norm and does not necessarily any like
correlation pretended to half the time
even the person I'm talking to you about
the game doesn't have any power or idea
when they are getting the code right
yeah and if I was definitely the case in
the UK as well actually when we were
getting games which were coming from
external simple like third-party your
company's a type so all right thank you
both